Alex here's a couple of titles that
you've done and let's get the ladies
responses to this Amber your game yeah
I'm already looking I'm excited but
a uh title how to text a girl like a pro
so Alex in a very succinct way how do
you text a girl like a pro
how do you text a girl like a pro
um there's some basic fundamentals that
go into texting that I think a lot of
guys don't realize the first part is the
opener which is getting the conversation
started the second thing you're doing is
You're Building investment bantering
vibing whatever you want to call it
which is basically getting the girl to
write to you the more invested the girl
is the less likely she is to flake the
more likely she is to show up the more
likely you are to get an outcome then
after that you have uh you know uh
screening making sure she's looking for
the same thing as you so if you want to
get laid you'll want to go out with like
a prude virgin or something like that
and then you're setting up the date and
then confirming and that's literally the
fundamentals of texting it sounds like
it's sales it's successful I worked in
sales for six years so yeah that's where
a lot of my shoes came from so you're
saying that it's too formulate because
that mean is that like a word for
formula I just think men are so
calculated with everything well an
expert you have to be as a guy
it's not natural for you to just like
understand emotional intelligence and
like what is it's not for for them it's
really not no guys in the beginning will
literally ask you questions so they can
learn about you and be that guy that you
want them to be and then three months
into it they'll just be the real them
and you're like oh [ __ ] I got [ __ ] and
hooked you know what I mean like they
just hook hook line
I can tell you're one of them I can tell
you one of what oh tell me what you mean
by that what I just said so what I think
you ask women questions yes so you can
learn about them and be the guy that
they want you to be with them to be you
whatever yeah you said it right yeah and
then after a while you're like I'm bored
of this [ __ ] [ __ ] and then you just
play you're only half right but don't
women you're only half right don't don't
women do like when you ask questions
about like what do you like what's
important but you know because I'm not I
don't I'm not I don't go into it with
like intention of like not being myself
three months from now hold on hear me
out hear me out she just called me out
here let me just respond let's go you're
only half right what's the other half
that I'm not ready yeah the first part
is yes the guy is asking the questions
listen I've worked in sales for 15 years
probably even 20 years at this point
selling isn't telling selling is asking
how the hell do I know what you're into
unless I ask you what you're into am I
because a girl aren't gonna is gonna
start asking me questions what I
literally only go on dates with guys who
don't ask questions
if you're confident in who yourself I'm
not lying about anything but are you
asking them those questions with the
intent of being that guy that they want
you to be and then eventually you're
going to be like yourself which is not
what they want that's the point that I
think you got wrong about me but I think
a lot of you guys do that dick size
right
thank you Nicky shout out
um
but guys the guys should be asking the
one questions very I'm talking about on
dating apps girls are not hitting you
back Alex you're the expert here like
hey so where do you live what are you up
to this weekend yeah what are we doing
like no the guy's job is to do that you
have to care the guy's job it's the real
the girl in correct yeah but it doesn't
mean you have to pretend to be someone
else or put on like a charade correct
first of all it's not even really
effective because the girl is going to
see through the act so if you're a guy
who's like super timid and you come off
and you're like trying to be assertive
that's going to be really obvious and
the girl is going to pick up on that
maybe on the first question on the first
date yeah yeah yeah so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire
saucecast click right here
foreign